[Musique]
le speak english abla espagnol par la
taille à nos vingt deux reprises 2 h
ta gueule et là monsieur bonsoir
si l'émission humoristique d'affaires 3
et wii avec une première histoire
l'histoire de deux choix qui seront
faits
la seule émission qui dérègle même votre
téléviseur celui ci mais madame amedeo
possédons pas bon vous étiez en quelle
tenue du cognac
gt non non non madame alors bon vous
étiez comme ça avait pas de provocation
de votre part ça s'est passé à quel
endroit ça s'est passé là bas non vous
êtes gentil quand on vient déposer
d'écouté que les trois gardes et c'est
tout elle va me laisser placer un mot
quand on vient déposer une plainte
on a le nom de la rue où ça s'est passé
sont encore là on peut les arrêter
d'accord vous allez prendre le nom de la
désolation pour le match vous êtes
gentils une seconde non on vous a volé
de sa violation pour le match dans la
boîte j'étais garé dans le couloir de
salaire une somme vous arrêter une
seconde monsieur imposer ça ne marchait
pas être gentil monsieur aussi a droit
de venir déposer une plainte on est
encore en république bon sens maintenant
j'arrive en salle ou pas voulu avec moi
je vous propose de venir avec vous on va
on va repérer un petit peu les lieux
madame bon c'est fait vous alors vous
écouter vous êtes gentils vous allez
relever le nom de la rue et vous venez
de me déposer votre plein on va pas
perdre du temps avec ça c'est fait c'est
fait alors là on va aller voir sur place
des invitations pour le match de ce soir
de ce sera les chiens
[Musique]
à
problème de fuite vous à confort vient
de mettre au point une nouvelle couche
avec france protectrice deux fois plus
efficace
problème deux fils n'hésitez pas nous
avons fort
formidable et nouvelle france pro des
crises amis lecteurs
les mémoires de paul ethnique à
l'histoire d'une caissière pas comme les
ouïes les grands noms écrivent
aujourd'hui des livres même les
speakerines écrivent leur mémoire ce qui
devait arriver arrive puisque les
caissières de grandes surfaces s'y
mettent aussi
et avec son livre est bien notre ami
paul ethnique à des passe en ce moment
les ventes d'un livre
ce livre d'evelyne leclerc sur les
mémoires d'une speakerine paul et nika
pour vous présenter
je vais vous dire que vous êtes à vous
seuls dix ans de grandes surfaces
dix ans de supermarché ça commence
comment cette histoire fabuleuse
ça commence un peu bas âge de 14 ans oui
rencontre dans la rue monsieur grisou
lui-même chef de rayon de supermarché
juste à côté de chez moi qui me dit
vas-y ma petite paulette je pense que tu
as de la rien alors qu'un marché
il ya un moment savoureux un moment tout
à fait incroyable quand vous passez
directement de la machine à touches
manuel à la caisse enregistreuse
automatique ça je peux dire que c'était
un moment fabuleux parc h 27 jours c'est
la page 27 exactement entre la page 26
et la page et dan s'est fait est
formidable
mieux on n'a pas accepté comme ça
c'était du design retravaillé sur les
manuels pense que
la chronique il ya eu des contacts de
travail à vous excuser la rue provost et
s'il vous plaît ami policier
un récent décret du ministère vous
demande d'être encore plus courtois avec
les étrangers la rue beauvau mais
écoutez c'est la première grotte ça va
vous voyez allez-y qu'elle est
aujourd'hui encore l'article que vous
aimez bien avant riboud est pourquoi les
boules parce que la dynastie des ebooks
la princesse nadimi mook est finalement
rentré au service du marquis de sade
mais le pinceau l'élu inquiet est sur
ses gardes décide d'aller la chercher
mais je crois que j'arrive à temps un
alors la voilà la demeure du marquis
fade
ynwa pourquoi
de mont st
dis moi pourquoi tu m'en soucie
on
de la vie
en vain
vacances
[Musique]
matin
sourire
et tout
[Musique]
oh
jean
je ne
[Musique]
on
chance
[Musique]
nadine la dynamique la bb bon on est
mais m gentil tu va te changer tout de
suite tu veux mettre ta culotte en dit à
exxon et tu va nous servir à table
j'attends un invité jean-marie quoi la
dernière veillée vous je veux bien matin
que l'automatisme il n'est pas du tout
question que je serve à table maintenant
sur la toile voir et en plus tu wafa tu
devenu comme une chiffe molle je
m'ennuie avec toi mais je préfère te
donner ma démission
j'ai deux petites manches je vais
redevenir méchant comme avantia écoute
bien su tout de suite espèce de chien
elle s'accroît pas gravés aux noms
nadine jean je t'aime je tenais bien je
suis tout de suite
qu'est-ce que je fais là on l'a échappé
belle
je suis ce que c'est que le market pas
de gta on sait qu'il est fatigué et las
se coiffe indique tabac fessée
déculottée mattek sands ah bon tu me
suis bien c'est pas facile en bas
[Musique]
ah ah
petits pains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
on dit d'un adolescent qui dégage un
gras quand il a des boutons des rougeurs
des points noirs contre cela il existe
des pommades vous ne l'ignorez pas
maintenant les laboratoires claira zone
viennent de mettre au point une nouvelle
méthode rapide et plus efficace
consultez directement sur place nos
spécialistes
[Musique]
merci claira zone
ça ne devrait pas des noms rejoignent
sow
nous sommes
tous
soit
[Musique]
johann tschopp lecture de plus
comme nous
je ne sais pas
les guerres
son sort oui ben margot héros
[Musique]
stephen âmes apéro
en effet
[Musique]
pour
mais quelle est cette étrange et
mystérieux ballet mais oui c'est bien ça
et c'est une première
c'est l'inquiétant ballet des polices
parallèles
[Musique]
et
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
satisfaction pour jean paul clave tout
de suite car son téléphone s'il vous
plaît le claf
ils sont nous qui était pas jours agités
bref ici vite et ça va mieux savais tu
as vraiment clavier qui va mieux
mensonge je vais pouvoir briser sa
compagne chez les garçons machine à
calculer ce bouquet chéri et je crois
que c'est une bonne nouvelle
les chiffres sont en hausse comme
logique de toute façon faut que je me
suis un gars ont répondu ses jt on a
pris mon talent moral en ce moment il
faut que j'aille là tu revois toujours
cet brebis galeuses la routine 19h45
déjà je suis trop sous ça ne fait pas
plaisir de regarder une photo du clan
perrine comme autrefois
berson une photo du clan s'il vous plaît
c'était quand même le bon temps
au final garçon un café désolé madame
permet à la machine à café et comment
mais j'aime rien dans cette maison
[Musique]
oui aux mineurs et à chaque sortie anna
philouze hp bahreïn vélo d'olt
attachmate ride
[Musique]
nec est trop
shu
bah
[Musique]
parra
[Applaudissements]
il est évident qu'un jour on nous donne
l'électronique n'a pas été facile alors
que des annonces de marchés à côté de
moi le rock de marineland
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]